good morning John Esther day I'll get
there originally a promise people who
don't know who asked her well she was an
awesome nerdfighter who did a lot of
amazing things with her friends and we
really loved her and she would have
turned 17 today if she had not died
because of the cancer inside of Esther
is the reason why John and I are always
wearing bracelet which you can buy
dftba.com they're five dollars and all
the proceeds of course go to this star
won't go out foundation which helps
children with cancer and their family so
last year when Esther was really sick
John said to her Esther we will do
whatever you want us to do on your
birthday in perpetuity whatever you want
we will do that and she could have been
like I want you to shave your head I
want you to wax your chin I want you to
eat a hamburger made out of compact
discs but now Esther it was like I want
you guys every year on my birthday to
talk about family and love so this is
very sweet but she awesome she has she
know she was doing here because John and
I have had a long-standing agreement to
not use the l word when talking about
one another and up to that point there
had been much discussion in
nerdfighteria like why don't you guys
don't talk about how you'd love each
other in your video blog so
righteousness forest
but despite the fight the people are
always asking us to do what john and i
do not use the l word this is a
long-standing agreement like from birth
but Esther told us to and when someone
that you respect is about to die you do
what they tell you to do you know but
here's the thing about Esther day is
something that she asked it to do a
little bit for her and a little bit for
nerdfighteria but mostly I think it's
something she asked us to do for
ourselves and that's pretty special from
the perspective of being kind of both at
the beginning of her life
and very much at the end of her life she
had I think a special kind of wisdom
that we shouldn't ignore knew that
loving each other is pretty much the
most important thing that we do it's not
just the reason that each of us as
individuals exist it's the reason why
like our species is if there is why our
civilization exists it's the only reason
why we can do these Marvel's magnificent
human thing John knows that I love him
even if I don't say it but like
Dumbledore said words have power and we
have to use the magic of our words on
each other so that we can
feel it experience it in the people that
we love know viscerally and without a
doubt how we feel so we have to use the
power of our words
it's esterday that's what this is about
tell the people that you love that you
love them so that they know dad I love
you for being a excellent father and
helping us out when we need it never
complaining about how weird your sons
are mom I love you for being proud of
your sons
even when they were doing weird weird
things that didn't make any sense to
anybody and John I will get to you later
to come to this video let us know who
you love and how you're gonna tell them
that you love them and also in the comes
of this video yeah hi I missed a video
and that was all my fault so you get to
punish me so punishment ideas as well
I'm sorry your pants is still down it
has been hacked and that is annoying but
YouTube comments still work or if you
want to leave them on Twitter hashtag
punish Hank John missed a video but
that's because he was having his abdomen
cut open and his gallbladder removed
though you don't get to punish him just
to be clear that's a medical exception
and yes VidCon was totally awesome that
is a poster with all of the the
signatures from all the speakers at
VidCon which is extremely cool that I
get to have it in my house we're gonna
auction off with the project for awesome
but until then it's 9:00 John I'm
looking forward to seeing your video
about VidCon on Friday I just assumed
that what you're gonna be doing I love
you